(drumming)
(whooshing and creaking)
(upbeat music)
- I've never dyed my hair.
I have no dying in to my hair
so we'll see what it's about.
- I'm not very nervous. Not very excited.
Afraid it's gonna hurt.
Just feels like my head's being painted.
- [Girl] I really hope
my hair doesn't fall out
'cause I super bleach it at home
but I have really great
expectations for this.
Like, I can't wait to have gray hair.
- I feel great right because I have
these nice ladies distracting me
from the fact
(ladies laugh)
that I'm bleaching my hair.
I'm going for, like Disney villain.
So, I have pretty high expectations.
- I don't have my glasses on
so I can't really see myself
but what I can see
(woman laughs)
I feel, like, I was like Cisco.
- I can see it going kind of blond.
- In order to go gray you
need to lift their hair
to the lightest yellow blond possible.
No way possible you get
it that late in one shot.
- Well, I just found out we're doing
round two of the bleaching so (laughs).
- It feels like Play-Doh in a plastic bag.
- It's looks pretty crazy right now.
- Well, the liner does strip
the hair from everything
- Mm-hm.
- that was in the hair strand
but the
- Yeah.
- b3 that we put in
the color helps deposit
proteins, conditioning agents.
So, even though we're
stripping out pigment
we're still adding in proteins and things
to keep your hair strong.
(upbeat music)
- I think I'm tearing up. It burns so bad.
- I'm feelin' pretty good right now.
So, I'm not crying like Leo.
- Feel like a practical joke right now.
- Three rounds of bleach.
- [Stylist] Three rounds of bleach.
- I feel the need to apologize
for how labor intensive it is.
- I thought it was gonna be way easier.
Kinda like a one two and go.
But no, we've been here for, I
think, like, three hours now?
- [Girl] Finally putting in the gray.
Oh, I don't know where I am right now.
So many chemicals right now.
- I'm really excited.
I mean, this was just the steps.
So, I don't know.
You don't know until it's all done.
- This part's the most surreal.
The getting my hair cut and just having
the hair falling off
green-gray is super strange.
- [Leo] I mean, to think about the fact
that just when I came in my hair was black
and now it is gray.
It's kind of impressive because
it's almost, like, magic.
- I was a super light-haired girl
so it's easier for them
but I couldn't imagine
what it's like for a dark haired person.
- [Girl] I have had thoughts about
whether this is, like, some
senior cultural appropriation.
- I love it.
- No.
- [Voiceover] With your glasses on?
Woah.
(laughs)
- [Voiceover] Look at that smile.
- That's crazy.
- I'm ready to take this
granny hair to the world.
Show some whipper snappers how it's done.
- And really well done.
My hair feels healthier
than before I came in.
So, it's great.
- I'm a fan. It's definitely different
and I don't know if I would, like
do it again because it takes so much,
such a long time to do it
so I definitely appreciate
what it actually is for fun
or for any reason.
- It was fun.
It felt like I was getting
my hair washed for,
like, four hours straight. I'm into it.
- But damn, do I look good.
I'm sorry, I love it.
Robin did an amazing job.
I feel like I have a
whole life ahead of me
even though I look kinda 80.
(gentle music)
(whooshing and creaking)